hey guys this is andrew for sharing
sensors.com so for those who are
watching my video for the first time let
me quickly introduce myself
i've been working as a professional
trainer on the option market for the
past six years in
hong kong and i've decided a few months
ago to do
some youtube videos because guys i want
to show you all the different tools and
techniques that portrayers actually
using at work
at least those that work for me and most
importantly guys i want to show you how
to use it yourself
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and actually
how to make money on the markets you
guys are in the right place
so today i want to make an update on
bitcoin let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys it's been a long time i
didn't do a video on the bitcoin uh
but you know this was my chart when i
opened the bitcoin on uh training view
and you know it's actually still good to
use
so let's use it so very quickly what you
see here is
idiot wave counting that i did
everywhere since inception
but i'm not going to go through this
here again and here
you're watching my feed extensions of
the
last move and this is what is
interesting it's giving me my levels all
right and i was right on
my first two levels so i said 35 000 is
going to be
a consideration area it was and 55 000
and it is
so the next one is 74 000. so i'm going
to get rid of this to
see more clearly what is happening so
now
i'm going to apply idiot wave theory to
this
fifth wave that is happening right now
and i'm going to try
to see what is missing where we might be
heading
so i know the level is 74 000 if we
develop
higher and i'm interesting to know if
maybe it is the last move
or not and i'm gonna try to get
information
from this market so the first thing i
want to show you guys
is the volumes that are quite
interesting
because you can see that there is a
pattern guys
all right so look
okay
you know what i mean we see guys the
volumes since
i'm only doing this in the in the last
wave because you know
this is the recent past so probably it's
gonna behave the same way
and i can see uh here it's not working
in this wave but
that all the time i had volumes
going getting lower lower lower and then
strong move up
you know here volumes going lower lower
and then
move up right now we're having a move up
with very decreasing volumes
so i expect a last move up guys but
let me show you something very
interesting here so once again
you can see that this was the counting i
did before once again idiot wave
principle
is a little game that consists of
finding the best counting that is
respecting all the rules of iliad
so idiot is a famous kind of
mathematician
that wrote a book in the 1930s that i
read
and that contains a lot of rules of
this wave theory that you need to apply
to make your accounting valid and once
you apply all of them and you can always
do it
almost always you have a lot of
information
from what you are doing so for those who
are interested about knowing more about
that
just click on the link in the
description of this video and you're
gonna receive right away guys a free
training that i did
by summing up the book for you and i
think it's much easier for you guys to
understand if you are new to this method
so here the information i have is
that uh most likely we're doing a fifth
wave that is going here
and look i have something and i have the
volume that are decreasing here as well
so i expect the volume to kick in soon
and to give us this last move up so we
are above the moving averages we are
bullish guys we are going to 74 000
i'm kind of convinced of that and i see
something else guys that is a bit
more worrying is that actually i think
that this is going to be
the maximum before uh kind of you know
deeper correction
at least maybe till the end of the year
and i'm not sure what it's going to
correct you know you can correct like 2
30
can correct 50 but i think that we have
this last move up and i'm going to show
you guys
here why so in this fifth wave that
we're doing
i see some weakness so the first
weakness is the volume that are not
kicking in
and i can see here that this is an
ending diagonal guys so once again i
explained very well what is an ending
diagonal in this
training but an ending diagonal is
showing weakness
all right
so maybe we're going to have something
like this and
if we do this is the force wave and it's
going below the
highest level of the first wave when you
have this force wave that is going below
the number one that you have here this
is showing weakness this is
uh showing that the market is out of
steam and this is usually what we see
in fifth waves uh because actually the
buying power
is not strong enough to you know just
push the price higher but in a uh you
know
more impulsive way and usually we have
this kind of
wedge pattern that are happening you
know so i'm
you know seeing it here and my scenario
let's see guys if i'm correct my
scenario is this all right we're gonna
move like this
so i give until the
10th of may to reach
74. okay let's call it 75 000
you know because the market likes a
round number
so i give it until the 10th of may to go
to 74 000
and then guys uh careful if the signal
is gonna given by this trend line once
it's going to get broken here
so if it's not if we're moving higher
it's not the time to sell but if we
break this trend line
so careful with that this is going to be
the signal that it's time to exit
and we is probably going to have some
deeper correction
in time and spot so guys that's it for
me i hope you enjoyed this video and if
you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys